i'm shannon bream i'm tom chalu i'm
maria bartoramo and this is the fox news
rundown
wednesday december 22nd 2021 i'm jessica
rosenthal it's been two weeks since the
president spoke to russia's president
and yet things seem to be getting even
more tense between russia and ukraine
u.s officials react to vladimir putin's
new warnings and demands this is doing
nothing to calm tensions there needs to
be better clarity we are willing and
nato has said this too willing to have
discussions to see if we can de-escalate
but there has to be a willingness on the
russian side
i'm dave anthony president biden keeps
urging americans to get vaccinated
against covet mandating it for some
telling those who don't they risk their
lives and others they've made a tactical
error because they have very much
uh deepened the divisions within the
country
and i'm robert jeffress i've got the
final word on the fox news rundown
[Music]
this week russia's president vladimir
putin told his defense officials that if
the aggressive line of our western
colleagues continues we will take
adequate military technical response
measures and he said react harshly to
unfriendly steps last week russia put
out a new security proposal demanding
that all nato related military activity
stop in eastern europe and demanded that
nato not offer ukraine membership
certainly not a ramping down of any
rhetoric since his virtual meeting with
president biden on december 7th but i
made it very clear
if in fact
he invades ukraine there will be severe
consequences
severe consequences economic
consequences like none he's ever seen or
ever have been seen in terms of being
imposed
he knows his immediate response was he
understood that on tuesday secretary of
state anthony blinken said they're
engaged in diplomacy and deterrence at
the same time here and that since that
virtual meeting the build-up of troops
around ukraine has become a deep concern
as they witness russia's plan to commit
renewed acts of aggression against
ukraine we have worked
in very close coordination
with allies and partners not only
to show
the shared concern but
to put in place what would be a very
meaningful
and massive response if russia commits
renewed acts of aggressions adding that
president biden has posited a much
better path forward diplomacy that would
of course require russia to agree and
de-escalate however at this time there's
no planned meeting between president
biden and russia's president putin well
i think what's definitely clear is that
things are not growing less tense
pentagon spokesman john kirby he still
has a significant force
build up around ukraine to the north to
the east and even to the south and
that's worrisome it's also not clear
what his intentions are and so comments
such as what has been reported obviously
don't do anything to lessen tensions uh
or to give the international community
a sense of
certainty about where this is going to
go
and so for our part we're going to
continue to consult with our allies and
partners about what they're seeing
their perspectives we're going to share
with them what our perspectives are and
we're going to continue to work with
them on a range of options that might be
available to leaders in this case in our
case president biden to try to make sure
that the the right outcome happens here
and that is that there is no other
incursion into ukraine that the
territorial integrity and sovereignty of
ukraine is respected and that things
actually do get more stable and and not
less
we know the president obviously had a
recent call with mr putin and after
russia laid out its
new security proposal demanding that
nato stop any military activity
in what it called former soviet
republics nato issued a pretty sharp
statement saying they're very concerned
about what they called unprovoked
unjustified military buildup along
ukraine's border and they said this nato
will take all necessary measures to
ensure the security and defense of nato
allies
any further aggression against ukraine
would have massive consequences
what are we to make of that i mean how
do things calm down after sort of a
ratcheting up of statements and rhetoric
well again the ratcheting up of uh
rhetoric and statements is on russia
not only because like statements like
you just said but also
in terms of their massive build up along
the border which they have not been
clear about what the intentions are so
you see what you're seeing and hearing
from
nato as an alliance but also nato allies
individually
mirrors very closely to what we're
saying here in the united states
this is doing nothing
to calm tensions there needs to be
better clarity we are willing and nato
has said this too willing to have
discussions with the russians uh some
kind of dialogue going forward to see if
we can de-escalate um but there has to
be
a willingness and an openness uh on the
russian side uh to be reciprocal in that
regard and again it's uh we're we're
still trying to work our way through
that and
and we want to get there there was a
report that the us and uk had sent cyber
security experts to ukraine to help them
prepare should russia attack the
country's critical infrastructure
um i guess much the way they're
suspected to have done in 2015 when they
shut off the power in a large part of
ukraine
how much of a cyber security threat does
russia pose here as we're all focusing
and talking about troops on the border
i mean we have seen the the russians
sort of use this playbook in the past
they are
not at all bashful about using
cyberspace uh to affect their ends and
means sometimes it's to spew
disinformation and propaganda to to try
to confuse and to dispel
truth uh out there in the information
space sometimes it's it's it's even more
nefarious and more tactical uh using uh
cyber operations to disrupt whether it's
critical infrastructure or security
systems to infiltrate to to steal
secrets from other nations they are
proficient in using cyber operations
to what they believe is their advantage
and we have to assume
that they
will continue to lean on that uh that
domain cyber domain to try to affect the
kinds of results that they they want to
achieve
i won't speak to the specific report
about assistance that the united states
may or may not be giving ukraine i will
just say that we are committed to
helping ukraine defend itself and you
saw that bear itself out quite tangibly
in just the last couple of weeks where
we completed a 60 million dollar package
of
of both lethal and non-lethal assistance
to ukraine to help them again defend
themselves
on afghanistan um there are reports from
several ngos that afghans are going to
starve and i've already seen i'm sure
you have two pictures of emaciated
children
we've already heard reports that some
have starved to death
we certainly didn't see reports quite
like this when the us was in country
so what are we the united states going
to do about these potentially
catastrophic
scenes that we may see out of
afghanistan well nobody wants to see a
humanitarian crisis in nf afghanistan
nobody obviously um is comforted by by
images of of uh starving
people certainly starving children um
and the united states will continue to
work with the international community to
help alleviate humanitarian needs in
afghanistan and we obviously call on the
taliban
to
receive to welcome and and to make sure
the distribution of humanitarian needs
uh are done in accordance with the
actual need out there on behalf of the
afghan people
but is this our fault i mean we didn't
see reports like this when we were there
i mean how much
i mean it's it's hard to ask but how
much blame do we have for this situation
i i think this isn't you know an issue
that i think should devolve into
finger-pointing or blame
it it was the right decision for the
united states military
uh to end its mission in afghanistan
that the president made it clear that
that our mission in afghanistan had been
accomplished many years ago
and we had invested an awful lot in the
afghan national defense and security
forces who unfortunately were not able
to use
all the resources and the help that that
they got from the international
community but i think it's hard when you
look back and you say well 20 years and
so where's the commitment my goodness
the commitment was in two decades two
full decades of commitment by the
american military and the american
government as well as our allies and
partners in afghanistan to get that
country into a much better place
it would be too easy right now to just
cast blame and i don't think that's
helpful for anybody it's certainly not
going to be helpful for afghans that are
in need right now what the international
community needs to continue to do is
look for ways to get them the
humanitarian assistance that they need
and to hold the taliban accountable
they're now the government
hold them accountable for making sure
that that aid gets to where it needs to
go
i want to ask about civilian casualties
because the new york times
has said in their investigation after
visiting more than 100 sites where
civilian casualties happened
um specifically in iraq and syria that
the civilian death toll is likely far
higher
than the 1400 that is in the pentagon
documents and they allege that america's
air wars has been marked by deeply
flawed intelligence rushed and imprecise
targeting and the deaths of thousands of
civilians including children
what is the pentagon's response to that
investigation
we uh have said many times
in the in recent weeks
that
that we know we need to work harder to
prevent civilian harm
and as secretary austin said himself uh
uh obviously we have more work to do um
and i think it's important to remember
too
these are often very difficult decisions
for commanders to make on the ground um
and we're dealing with enemies who
unlike the united states uh has no
compunction about putting civilians uh
in in harm's way uh knowing that we try
to take care to avoid civilian harm so
um i think there's a there's an awful
lot to get at here and as the secretary
has said himself we're willing
to dig into it to learn uh to try to
grow to try to get better and to make
improvements again in procedures
processes and rules of engagement so
that we can continue to try to drive
down instances of civilian harm again
nobody wants to see innocent civilian
lives taken or injured as a result of
u.s military operations and we work very
hard
but clearly we certainly have more work
to do
of course thank you for that on on china
before we announced a diplomatic boycott
of the olympic games china's foreign
ministry asked american companies to
speak out and speak up on behalf of
beijing
we know jp morgan chase for example has
recently been allowed by chinese
officials to become the first foreign
company to run a securities company
inside china
we've heard reports that apple's ceo tim
cook made a deal with chinese officials
to spend billions of dollars in the
country
as we talk about an increase in tensions
with china
does the pentagon ever look at corporate
american interests in china
as like a national security issue
because we've already heard that having
all of our stuff made in china like
medical supplies during a pandemic is a
national security issue so do
corporate interests in china ever rise
to that level
well what i would say on that issue i
mean obviously um
we have a
economic bilateral relationship with
china which is massive and it's
important it's important to both
countries
and that's why
you know we
don't
want to see
the relationship with china uh
come to blows and there's no reason for
it to
we here in the department though we're
tasked with defending the nation and so
our focus is on meeting the pacing
challenge that china represents china
continues to invest in capabilities
that are designed in many ways to limit
our freedom of action in the
indo-pacific particularly the western
indo-pacific they continue to bully and
coerce and intimidate their neighbors
with false
maritime claims and other geographic
claims
to try to
expand their
their influence in ways that uh actually
fly in the face of international law
we have five of our seven treaty
alliances in the pacific five of seven
and a lot of americans don't understand
that we have very serious security
commitments over there to allies and
partners who are feeling that pressure
right now from china so we're focused
also on
revitalizing these alliances and
partnerships and making sure that that
our friends in the indo-pacific know
that we are there that that american
leadership uh will remain and will
and will be steadfast to our shared
national security interests and the
other thing that we're doing is working
on our own capabilities you've heard
secretary austin talk about something
called integrated deterrence this is not
just being able to better net and
integrate our own capabilities in
technology but to better net and
integrate the technology and the
capabilities of our allies and partners
so that we can send a very clear message
to china from a military perspective
that when we say we want to deter
conflict we mean it and we have the
capabilities to do that
john kirby thank you so much for your
time appreciate it
my pleasure thanks for having me
[Music]
this is robert jeffress with your fox
news commentary coming
up
covid is spreading like wildfire again
with the new omicron variant i know
you're tired
i really mean this and i know you're
frustrated
we all want this to be over
or still in it so president biden urges
us again get facts in it now it's free
it's convenient
i promise you it saves lives calling it
a patriotic duty and for those who
haven't you're at a high risk of getting
sick and if you get sick you're likely
to spread it to others including friends
and family saying while shots and
boosters don't prevent all infections
they are much milder almost everyone who
has died from cover 19 in the past many
months
has been
unvaccinated the president also promised
more testing sites and a half billion at
home test kits the government will
provide us free
at a time when his handling of covet
with mandates has met with more public
disapproval when he took office the
public very much approved of the way
that he talked about and his handling of
the issue of coronavirus tom bevin is
co-founder and president of real clear
politics that remained even above his
overall job approval rating he was in
the 60s there through about the middle
of the year um and
since suffered a pretty rapid
deterioration of that so i think the
public by and large doesn't approve of
the way that he's been handling things
i'm not sure that this is going to reset
or reboot uh this new plan which
involves sending you know 500 million
tests
uh to to people at home which is an idea
the administration kind of brushed off
just a couple of weeks ago you know back
on july 4th he was up there declaring
independence from kovat and and then we
had accomplished yeah and then we had
delta yeah and now we have omicron
listen if you want to fault the
administration the the administration
made a conscious decision when delta
happened and and they saw resistance
from
to new restrictions in places like
florida and the president came out if
you remember and he said instead of
instead of working with red state
governors to say hey how can we get more
people in your state vaccinated there
seems to be some hesitancy what can we
do you know what messaging can we do
because the governors of these states
all you know are in favor of vaccination
they may not be pushing it as hard as as
the administration wanted but instead of
doing that he came out and said listen
and he said very specifically even ron
desantis by name and said if you're not
going to be part of the solution i'm
going to move you out of the way and you
see that again from biden himself and
from one of his
from one of his public health officials
just a couple of days ago basically
saying listen for the vaccinated you're
doing a great job congratulations and we
hope you're you're you know you have a
happy holiday and for the unvaccinated
you're facing a winter of severe illness
and death
and you know you're going to overwhelm
these hospitals i mean it's really grim
stern
language that is even among some
democrats they're like wait who who are
you trying to convince with this
rhetoric i think in that sense they've
made a tactical error because they have
very much deep in the divisions within
the country the other day vice president
harris said that the administration
wasn't prepared for omicron and then the
white house is like oh no no no no we we
knew variants were coming she just means
that omicron was
so much more contagious than we than we
kind of expected it to be
that is again a time in which the
president and the white house and the
vice president don't seem to all be
aligned here what do you think is going
on between the two well that one to me
is just
more
evidence that kamala harris just does
not have the political chop she's just
not good at politics it doesn't take a
political genius to answer questions in
a way that doesn't get the
administration paint them as being
either incompetent or asleep at the
switch because
it's not like i don't think she was
specifically trying to indict biden
because she's part of the administration
and she's been involved in this so is it
possible that she's trying to distance
herself a little bit from him by saying
oh we haven't even talked about 2024. if
he's not doing well and he's going down
in his approval ratings why would she
want to link herself if he's not going
to run again potentially in 2024
wouldn't it be better for her if she had
her own narrative
i don't know that she can
separate herself distance herself from
biden if she wanted to
um i do think there's real tension
between the two offices there's no
question
the way that the leaking and jockeying
and has been going on and we've been
reading reports in the press i also
think
you know when biden says he's going to
run again
he kind of has to say that otherwise
he'd sort of self-declare
to be a lame duck within the first year
of his administration which would be
catastrophic yeah what's he going to do
for the next three years right i mean
he has no power left yeah exactly i mean
so even though he says he's running
again nobody believes that and i include
kamala harrison that she doesn't believe
he's running again either you know she's
going to face a she's going to face
primary challenges from one or more
people if she wants to become the leader
of the party she hasn't proven to be a
particularly strong or good candidate
that has been able to unify democrats
and so i think it just points to the
dilemma that democrats are in moving
forward is they don't really have a
settled leader of their party and and
that could become a problem for them
i've heard people mention hillary
clinton i mean she read her
supposed victory speech that she didn't
find you know online and and some people
thought that was wonderful and she was
courageous her supporters certainly did
so
is that a possibility still within the
realm of possibilities with the clintons
you never count them out there's always
a third act or a fourth fourth hack you
know they still want to be involved and
she still
believes herself to be she won the
popular president
for the for the democratic party to go
backwards to the clintons at this point
i think would be just insane
it's going to be someone like you know
dwayne the rock johnson or oprah or
michelle obama somebody with
sort of electrifying star power that
would be able to by sure sheer virtue of
their
charisma try and unite the party because
i just don't hillary clinton does not
fit that bill i just can't imagine that
they would do that democrats may have an
even bigger problem in 2022.
after one of their own senator joe
manchin came out against their nearly
two trillion dollar social spending plan
if i can't go home and explain it
to the people of west virginia i can't
vote for it after saying that on fox
news sunday many democrats say mansion
betrayed them asked about it after his
covet speech yesterday president biden
said some people
think maybe i'm not irish face i don't
hold a grudge
look i want to get things done i still
think there's a possibility of getting
pulled back better done so they'll try
again in january the longer it drags on
in the new year
and gets closer to the election it's
it's either going to reinforce the idea
that the democrats just don't have their
stuff together and can't can't get it
together and that's turning off
independence in particular
and if they don't get something done if
they drag it on for another you know few
weeks and still end up with nothing
that's going to depress the democratic
base i mean which you have to have in a
midterm election
you have to turn out your base you have
to win independent and swing voters too
but you can't
you know if you win swing voters but
lose your base you're going to lose and
so
it is it's a really tough position for
the democrats and they there is no
obvious
plan b alternative can you make the
direct comparison i've seen people try
to make this between joe manchin and
john mccain and the obamacare
rewrite that republicans tried under
president trump's first year in office
and it failed because the maverick from
arizona wouldn't go along with his party
he was praised by a lot of people for
putting country over party mansion
hasn't gotten as much praise certainly
in the media like mccain got for being
the maverick am i am i wrong
no you're not wrong about that and and
you know it's funny i mean people were
democrats and progressives were upset
that that he decided to go on fox news
on a sunday show and and make this
announcement that was no coincidence and
they he was really just you know trying
to do that despite progressives imagine
imagine what democrats and the media
would have done to joe manchin had he
waited until
he was the very last senator to vote
standing on the floor in the well of the
senate at midnight
and to go up there and cast what
everyone thought was going to be the the
the final yay vote to get this thing
across and gave it the thumbs down which
is exactly what mccain did i mean they
would have gone
nuts like a hundred times more nuts than
they did on him
for the way that he currently did it so
yeah i mean look the the
the media coverage the tone is different
mansion is not being seen or portrayed
as being a hero and putting you know
country above party he's been portrayed
as
a sellout
someone who sold out his constituents
and is voting against their interests
and their desires and whatnot i
mentioned former president trump he told
fox on sunday remember biden was going
to do a wonderful job on covid right he
was going to do a wonderful job he's
done a horrible job he still claims the
election was stolen and plans to hold a
news conference january 6th one year
after the capital riot the democrats and
some republicans blame him for inciting
he calls the house committee
investigating that political hacks and
despite claims of fraud going nowhere in
court the former president maintains the
real insurrection was on election day
not the unarmed protest he's clearly not
going away and folks you know who who
talk to him and are close to him
continue to say that he's definitely
running in 2024. i guess the good news
for republicans is that it's hard to
as much as the democrats will try and
even if he's out there and he's making
endorsements and he's playing around in
the 2022 election he's not on the ballot
but to the extent that trump is
decides to run in 2024 you know he's
he's going to be and and all he wants to
do is relitigate 2020 and continue to
insist that he was you know the election
was stolen
etc
i think that's going to be a real
problem for the republican party because
he is the most popular republican in the
party if he wants to run he will win the
nomination i don't think there's anybody
who could stop him if he gets involved
in 2022
do you think some of the republicans he
he's backing will certainly not want to
be part of him on a stage within the
rigged election over and over and over
again because that's not a topic that
they want to really talk about as they
look forward to trying to take over
congress
it depends on where the landscape is too
i mean right now you look at the generic
congressional ballot republicans are
leading in our real politics average by
about two and a half points in some
polls they have been up as much as 10
points if the landscape is that good for
republicans
you know and that bad for democrats it's
going to matter a whole lot less
uh
how much trump is involved but a lot of
time between now and november yeah i
mean what happens if
we really do have a much better 2022 and
the pandemic starts to really look like
we're getting more toward an end than
ever before i mean that would really
help the president and the democrats
right
sure i mean to the extent the pandemic
passes i think the bigger issue for
democrats quite honestly is the economy
and inflation
people are just absolutely you know
they're looking around at gas prices and
food prices
if if inflation starts to come down then
i think the democrats will be in a lot
better position if it stays where it is
it keeps getting worse even if the
pandemic passes to a certain degree if
the pandemic is still raging and
inflation is raging i mean there you
know it's going to be a bloodbath i mean
there's just no question about it those
are the two
biggest issues on the minds of voters
right now and the administration hasn't
had an answer for either one of them to
this point tom bevin co-founder
president real clear politics always
good to talk to you happy holidays
thanks for joining us same to you dave
thank you
from the fox news podcasts network stay
on top of the latest news and
information from fox news listen and
download the fox news hourly update on
your time the trending stories you need
anytime you want it listen and download
now by going to foxnewspodcasts.com
rate and review the fox news rundown on
apple podcasts or wherever you listen
it's time for your fox news commentary
robert jeffress
what's on your mind one way you know
that the christmas season is starting is
by the continuous showing of the holiday
classic it's a wonderful life starring
jimmy stewart and donna reid you
probably know the story by heart stewart
plays george bailey a man who has
experienced a catastrophe at work
disheartened by his circumstances he
curses the day he was born and decides
to take his own life
an angel named clarence rescues him and
shows him what the world would have been
like if he had never been born through
the experience stewart's character sees
the value and impact of his life on so
many others so just imagine what would
the world be like if jesus christ had
remained in heaven and not crossed the
gulf of eternity into time and space
what if there were no christmas no birth
of jesus christ if christ had never come
our nation as we know it would not exist
america was founded on the idea that all
men are created equal and endowed by
their creator with certain inalienable
rights this singular truth led to the
end of slavery and fueled the civil
rights movement before christ came there
was no widespread belief in the inherent
dignity and equality of each person
no pre-christian political body ever had
attempted anything like the 14th
amendment which gives every single
person the full and equal protection of
the law
if christ did not come the daily lives
of most people would look drastically
different nearly every institution that
enriches our lives from charities to
hospitals to universities
was founded by christians who were
responding to what happened at christ
advent you cannot explain history's most
influential art and music are literature
and philosophy without reference to
jesus without christmas there would be
no sistine chapel or notre dame
cathedral no bach or beethoven no dante
or dostoyevsky the reason christ coming
elicited such a remarkable upheaval in
politics and culture and history is
because of what it means for people like
you and me the one who made us chose to
become one of us dorothy sayers said it
this way
god has himself gone through the whole
of human experience from the trivial
irritations of family life and the
cramping restrictions of hard work and
lack of money to the worst horrors of
pain and humiliation defeat despair and
death the good news of christianity
culminates on easter at an empty tomb in
jerusalem but it begins on christmas at
an animal feeding trough in bethlehem
no christmas no easter
no easter no forgiveness and no hope for
sinners like us
christmas is the annual reminder of the
wonderful fact that we don't ever have
to live in an alternate no christmas
reality because christ did come we have
a bible in which every prophecy has been
fulfilled we have a savior who has paid
the penalty for our sin we have a
sympathetic friend in heaven who
empathizes with our difficulties and we
have a hope waiting for us beyond the
grave
as the angel announced to the shepherds
on a judean hillside 2000 years ago
do not be afraid for behold i bring you
good news of great joy which will be for
all the people for today in the city of
david there has been born for you a
savior who is christ the lord
thank god there is a christmas
this is robert jeffress for fox news
you've been listening to the fox news
rundown stay up to date by subscribing
to this podcast at
foxnewspodcasts.com and for up to the
minute news go to foxnews.com
from the fox news podcast network
download and listen to everyone talks to
liz fox business's liz clayman talks
with entrepreneurs and executives about
inspiring and motivational stories
subscribe and listen now by going to
foxnewspodcasts.com
love fox news click the subscribe button
to get more of the news and opinion you
trust and click the fox news rundown
playlist for the latest episodes